hello I love the outfits thank you what
are we thinking I don't think you want
to know what I'm thinking right now
my name is Chris and Welcome to our new
show matched I've got my voice Sam and
Gabe here today and they're going to be
matching women's faces to their bodies
and if these guys get all of our women
right today they'll go home with a cash
prize we're gonna kill it
all right gentlemen this is about to
start round one let's reveal Our Ladies
hey there ladies damn dang y'all look
like Shia LaBeouf had a met done
I love the outfits all right gentlemen
once you are ready I will hand you that
lovely lady's face and you will be able
to match it once that lady is in front
of us okay all right contestant number
one come with me I'm gonna have you step
momentarily don't trip nice and turn
this way perfect you okay yes
what makes you think you'll be good at
matching women's faces to their bodies
well Chris I'm a self-certified ladies
man come on now look at the smile you
already know I listen to a lot of r b
music so I feel like I'm really in tune
with my feminine side hopefully I don't
get like no ladies attacking me like oh
you shouldn't have said that I think all
ladies are beautiful at the end beauty
is in the eye of the beholder get my
bifocals out you can ask questions okay
Gabe when you're looking at this when
for one this fine specimen
this is not a specimen it's a person
female yeah
my partner you're gonna throw me under
the bus
doing too much oh yeah everyone got some
attitude
okay a man saying a woman has an
she's a dangerous one allow me gentlemen
can I provide you with a fun fact this
contestant likes to pole dance as a
hobby pole dance like what are we
talking about nighttime daytime or what
it's like my gym it was like the first
time I really felt strong do you have
like a pole dance like the middle of
your house or something or in the middle
of your apartment I have a pole yes I
had to install it and you did it
yourself or did someone else do it yes
woman and stem woman instead
does that like it does that change what
you're feeling we're gonna make a ton of
judges right now
my God I was about to pray I was gonna
get on my knees and bow down to you for
a second you still can Brooke has this
like you know her look in her facial
it's kind of hard look right she's like
a two dude High key High key alley has
like a nice like English like the girl
in like your English classroom you know
I don't know man it's Brooke okay since
since you made the choice Sam go ahead
and attach that to our lovely be careful
be careful
I think almost everything they said was
dumb but I think just overall they're
very silly and we're here for a good
time all right gentlemen contestant
number two all right let's start what
are we thinking do you play any sports
not since I was like 11 11 what was that
score if you want me asking hockey
hockey oh lucky you you was really busy
other people with that you know how to
fight probably yeah yes Sienna you know
how that Latina attitude energy yeah
which I which I like the same time you
know like it just depends but it's one
of those aspects I do have a question
that we can also ask the contestant as
well okay what is your relationship to
your body
um well honestly very tricky I am a
trans woman okay so I grew up with not
the body that you see now oh the word
and the way I viewed my body has like
totally changed since starting my
transition because growing up as a
little boy you know you're told like you
have to have abs you have to have
muscles you have to look Burly I've been
told nothing's noticeable but well I'll
tell you this we're looking through all
the faces I could never even tell to be
honest I've seen a ton of faces and I
cannot oh my God you know but imagine a
few drinks in me oh my God now okay
number two what do you feel like uh you
you are most confident about you
honestly look at my face I was luckily
given my mom's face and not my dad's
face oh okay so I will say that it has
helped a lot
I'm really feeling this this image here
oh yo whoa what your room what do you
feel I honestly I'm not gonna lie Maxine
Max reason is a general neutral name
Max to be a feminine version of a male
name maybe I have a whole different name
I feel like she's playing for her
psychology with me right well you know
I'm gonna stick with my gut we're going
with Maxine right now I'm five five so
forgive me
[Music]
all right gentlemen contestant number
three okay ready I love your outfit by
the way I can give I can give a fun fact
about the 13. yeah our third contestant
is a small business owner and she makes
her own jewelry oh okay who looked like
they got that drips Erica I'm thinking
Erica a little bit right now I haven't
even answered any questions oh yeah yeah
let's add some more oh yeah yeah so I've
only given fun what's your zodiac sign
this is a good question I'm a Capricorn
a Capricorn I'm a Capricorn or do
Capricorns look a particular way in
there I'm assuming because representing
all the Capricorns around the world My
Heart Is Telling Me Erica I'ma trust my
partner on this one oh we asking any
other questions or uh I mean uh what's
your favorite type of food I love Thai
food is my favorite probably oh change
anything a glow key no it's changing my
mind I'm feeling Amy right now too
because you got the jewelry bro she's
got a different type of like diversity I
don't know where no but Amy looked like
she got like a peculiar type of jewelry
also Cadets number three loves anime
that plays into any preconceived hey
girls I love cosplay definitely dye
their hair man I'll be telling you that
don't you like anime scientifies the
types right wait what what's your
favorite color
my favorite color
um is green I don't think I also really
like girly stuff it depends on the day
either green or pink oh
my heart's telling me uh yeah the Heart
Will Go On yeah yeah put it on the heart
put it on I'll be completely wrong who
am I you are an angel nice
good
all right contest number four you ready
yes hello what's going on I like that I
love the outfit thank you what are we
thinking no how are we feeling I don't
think you want to know what I'm thinking
right now
thank you give me a turning everybody
said walking here and the boxes too they
don't even know what you're wearing I
actually put on a long sleeve because I
wanted to cover up a little bit more but
you know comments be comments just can't
let them get to you would we like a fun
fact about this yeah she is a heels
dancer could you show us a quick move
[Music]
okay I would do more I have a box so I
cannot there's only so much I can do
right right what's your favorite type of
food I'm in a Peruvian food era but
after before that I was at a Korean food
era Korean food when we see this girl
let's see Amy for example does she had a
conference just to walk out here and
just just teach me how to Dougie or what
uh I don't know I feel like
alien put some Vape around in the air
type of person another fun fact is that
this contestant is a power lifter what's
what's the weight you push on all three
I have a 265 squat a 300 dead and my
bench is very embarrassing but it's 115.
you do this all with nice pretty nails
too I like that no I actually I pulled
them off when I did yeah I was gonna say
yeah dang that's insane that's insane
that's impressive
as well consolidating Sam are you guys
I'm coming on all right thank you
I feel like there are some stereotypes
playing into here when they guess that I
was Asian especially after I said I
liked Korean food all right next up
we've got contestant number five don't
trip you gotta pull right there nice I
made it I'm alive yes you know what
accessor number five what's your typical
day like I like to sing I like to paint
I like to create content I like to make
comedy skits I like to read I don't know
I just do so much stuff I just can't
count it to be honest I just keep myself
busy oh I feel like that was our that
was quite decisive very early what are
we thinking it's getting is I don't know
why like our hearts are telling us this
yeah but we're also dudes so our heart
could also be stupid is there a fun fact
you got there is indeed contest number
five has 16 siblings no way ah yes yes
why why why does that make you respond
to that it's either between shaffir or
Sienna why because Sienna you know I'm
Latino so like all Latinos we have
families everywhere like we got a cousin
working at a taco shop across the street
okay we got an uncle working housing tie
walls I think you should fear because
you know she got that pink lipstick and
got the pink outfit and the pink nails
that's if I fellas if I don't say a
trifecta
there's a trifecta right there whenever
you're ready tag it up okay I felt like
we were right on the dot with this one
next up gentlemen contestant number six
what's cracking number six how you doing
what's up guys what's up what's a fun
fact about it okay yeah yeah and death
number six is currently studying to
become a high school art teacher art
teacher so you can draw
yeah like what type of drawing because I
can't draw I prefer to do other stuff
like mosaics and sculptures and stuff
but I can't draw by the way Lovely Nails
you have different colors I like you
just got them done yesterday I have
pride Nails on right now because it's
hashtag pride month so I will always
take a compliment on my rainbow
accessories gentlemen always caught up
with the nails let's compliment the
nails by lover boy right here come on
now okay all right pretty good how are
we feeling we only got two ladies
Natalie man Natalie this looks like I
had an art teacher named Natalie once
I'm gonna go with Natalie right now yeah
we're filming
we're gonna match it yeah I'm very
confident in this one
I don't know it felt a little picked
over but whatever guys well all right
you tell us you tell it okay you tell us
me
[Music]
all right we only got one person left
okay tell us a fun fact about yourself
number seven I am a huge music fan
specifically boy bands and I also really
enjoy reality TV you know I used to have
a cousin that was really into boy bands
that looks like her I I don't know man
but you know I'm just saying what boy
bands are you into like Big Time Rush I
like One Direction
[Music]
who's your favorite One Direction guy
Nyle
when we put Sienna on that we don't know
if it's number seven yet but at the same
time when we when we kind of want there
we want to kind of like you know see if
it matches
okay now tag it and bag it all right
that was quick
[Music]
ladies how do you feel do you feel great
right now are you doing good yeah
it makes reactions
that's really interesting I'm so sorry
all right Gentlemen We Begin round two
which means we're going to reveal our
contestants your cash prize is on the
line if you get one even one of these
wrong you lose all the money wow every
moment along the way we will be stressed
we'll start with number two this is
Maxine let's see
oh oh dude you're all right good job
good job all right we'll dive in another
random number number seven okay go ahead
and remove your box
oh I'm feeling dangerous
[Applause]
Brooke the pull day momentarily remove
your bucks
oh
okay three for three thank you wait a
minute number four let's be Amy come on
in move your box
number
[Applause]
six are you ready number six
remove your box Natalie Natalie yes
[Applause]
all right all right we're five for seven
still feeling
so we have two left if either one of
these is wrong means your cash prize is
done all right you still feeling good so
good and I'm feeling good so this is the
true moment all right all right
Gentlemen let's steal ourselves all
right we're gonna go with our next
random number
and that will be number three you ready
yeah I'm ready yes Erica remove your box
[Applause]
[Music]
I gotta say gentlemen good job if those
things were correct we'll jump to our
last number which is number five are you
ready number five
I feel like this is going to go to both
of your heads well I must say
congratulations ladies how did it feel
for you guys being you know judged for
solely your direct appearance and your
body in particular I thought it was cool
you know we're all different shades of
colors but you guys thought one was the
other person which I thought was
interesting like I would never have
expected to be maybe you know her body I
was really trying to throw you off and
say my favorite color is pink you know
I'm really really hoping that you would
get it wrong but uh were you pleasantly
surprised about anything you said you
were like oh wow that's actually really
thoughtful
um rather the detail the attention to
detail looking at aesthetic you were
paying attention to the whole package
you were you you guys came to play no
one yeah yeah everybody had their own
Essence to them your own oh we should
call it Divinity and you studied it the
Divine I think it was luck
maybe for seven yeah
luck
unfortunately you know they got it right
and I wish they didn't I think we were
all kind of rooting that we could mess
them up but they were pretty spot on
their guesses I think it's very common
and it's very stigmatized that trans
women just change their name like Max to
Maxine but it's a lot deeper than that
and to find your name especially as a
trans person is very it's a journey I
thought it was
feel like I have like a really
bubbly energetic personalities whenever
he spoke to Shaffer and like kind of
thought she was Latino because she was
like sassing a lot a lot of siblings
made me a little bit uncomfortable
because I feel like latinas get that a
lot I think they like to hear their own
voice a little bit Stokes right like I
didn't expect anything else for myself I
just feel like me and Sam were a great
team we've been knowing this from the
jump I am going to change a bunch of
lives with this money starting with my
credit card debt all right gentlemen
your winnings boom congratulations good
job good job and that was matched like
And subscribe drop a comment to let us
know what else we can match here and
we'll catch you guys next time